le poisson c'est plein de phosphore donc
c'est bon pour la mémoire vous l'avez
déjà entendu celle-là non alors bon
est-ce que le poisson contient beaucoup
de phosphore bah oui c'est pas faux mais
moins que le fromage et pas plus que la
viande ni que le vin donc dans l'absolu
une bonne vieille raclette c'est
infiniment plus riche en phosphore que
du vieux poisson bouilli tout dégueu bon
mais une phosphore alors est-ce que
c'est vraiment bon pour la mémoire non
parce que apparemment il y en a plein
dans le vent vous je sais pas mais moi
les lendemains de soirée je me rappelle
pas de tout et bah non c'est une vieille
croyance des années 70 sans réel
fondement scientifique mais manger du
poisson quand même c'est plein d'oméga 3
ah la soupe ça fait pas grandir